Democratic senator Cory Booker of New
Jersey serves on the Senate Judiciary &
Foreign Relations committees he's with
us from Washington good morning senator
I want to start with this let's forget
the word for a moment the Homeland
Security Secretary also didn't agree
that the president had grouped nations
in this in this fashion forgetting the
word do you believe that she told the
truth under oath yesterday in her
testimony John first of all welcome to
the show it's exciting to have you as
part of the morning show that I watch
and to your question she was not telling
the truth
she was an American citizen under oath
before a Senate committee and she
pretended like she didn't remember she
couldn't remember what the president I
states a commander and sheep her boss
was saying she didn't remember Lindsey
Graham who challenged the President on
his vile words yesterday it was so
offensive to me that she lied under oath
and it's not everybody wants to say it's
about the profanity it's not about the
profanity it's that the President of the
United States would speak in such a
bigoted manner against large groups of
people large groups who are represented
here in this country as our fellow
American citizens senator you called it
a moral moment for the country it seemed
really to strike a nerve with you what
do you mean well all of us know our
history in this country and throughout
the world and places like Europe that so
many folks said the opposite of justice
is not in justice it's silence
it's inaction in other words the
perpetrators of bigotry and hate that is
really bad but what is the worst thing
that allows hatred and bigotry to
proliferate is people who stand by and
do nothing when it said we in America
when we witness sexism or sentiments
against Catholics or Muslims or Jews or
blacks those of us who stand by and do
nothing are complicit in that ignorant
we all have got to as Americans say if
you come after a Catholic American if
you come after a Haitian American if you
come after a Nigerian America you're
coming after me and I'm gonna defend
that so what do you think of the
Republican senator because the way I see
it the Oval Office is not a big space
the President of the United States is
speaking and most people I know when
they go in the Oval Office you're
listening with both ears to anything
president has to say so to have
Republicans say I didn't hear it or its
mischaracterized what do you make of
that and what should be done about that
well I mean the one thing is I'm not
gonna take it and and that's why I did
get very upset with sitting there and
I'm one of the junior members of that
committee so I had to listen to her over
and over again to lies to my colleagues
I'm just not gonna take it all of us
should not be silent but you're right
how dramatic that is I've been in the
Oval Office I've had meetings with the
president with President Obama of small
groups large groups one on one when
you're in that room it is a sacred space
in our country you are all your senses
are heightened you know what the
president United States is saying
especially in heated conversations and
backs back and forth so there's just no
way
I buy that and I'll tell you talking to
others that everybody knows that this is
a lie it's a sham and it's not what
hurts me is why why would an American
under oath lie to protect their job
again that speaks to a dark history on
this planet of people obeying orders
doing their job what they're witnessing
injustice when they're witnessing things
that are words coming from power that
don't just dissipate in the wind they
give license to people understand we've
had 85 vicious attacks terroristic
attacks since 9/11 over 70% of them have
been from white nationalists people who
peddle in this kind of hatred and
bigotry people who have used Donald
Trump's words and their own
communications as showing that this is a
justification coming from the White
House who can't even condemn a white
nationalist marching in Virginia with
tiki torches this is gotta stop this is
not Republican or Democrat that's why
Lindsey Graham is such a hero in this
Republican from South Carolina because
he didn't remain silent he stepped up
and challenged the president senator
meanwhile the work of the American
people does not get done by either the
President or the United States Congress
the deadline to pass a budget bill has
passed the government shutdown looming
on Friday dreamers still without a plan
some of their parents being sent back
because they're not eligible for daca
pain and Families because of this are
you and fellow Democrat
willing to vote in favor of a short-term
bill that does not include a daca
solution well the irony even of what
you're saying he and the president in an
earlier meeting talked about let's just
be about love I'll accept any deal
that's brought to them Lindsey Graham
and dick Durbin and other of my
colleagues on both sides they all
hammered out a deal wasn't perfect to me
aspects I didn't like but it was a deal
that if it was put on the Senate floor
dealing with daca and dreamers it would
have gotten over 70 votes but yet they
rejected that deal and so this is an
artificial moment still put that on the
floor he should put it on the floor and
and and and remember this whole deadline
was not created by some kind of
mechanism and some kind of policy this
was the president iron states that
created this moment of Jeopardy created
this crisis a man who is obviously
president of states where Republicans
control the House and the Senate and he
claims to be the greatest deal maker
that God ever created well I'll tell you
what this is the time to make a deal and
get America out of this crisis we all
agree this important urgent work to do
but I for one am NOT going to leave
American citizens behind and I know
technically these folks are not American
citizens but they are in every way but a
piece of paper they serve in our
military there are first responders
there are teachers of our children
they've benefited from our public
schools from kindergarten on they've
served and so I'm not leaving any
American behind I'm not gonna vote on
something that isn't a part of this deal
when a part of this package when we know
there's a deal right before us but not
everybody likes but that's the nature of
compromise all right senator Booker
thank you very much for joining us we'll
have to leave it there thanks a lot
Thank You Gail